whereas to factor the polynomial below
is the product of two binomials and we
have n times n minus one
plus three times n minus one so i
encourage you to pause this video and
see if you can figure this out
well the key is to realizing that both
of these terms have n minus 1 as a
factor let me just rewrite the whole
thing so we can work on it down here so
this is n
times n minus 1
plus 3 times n minus 1. and notice both
of them have an n minus 1 have an n
minus 1 as a factor so we could do is
factor out the n minus 1 or you could
you could view it as undistributing the
n minus 1 and if we do that we're going
to factor out the n minus 1 and what are
we going to have left over well if you
take out the n minus 1 here if you
undistribute it out you're just going to
be left with
you are just going to be left with that
n so you're going to have an n there
and then
for this second term you factor this n
minus 1 out you're just going to be left
with this positive 3
plus 3. and just like that we are done
we have we have factored the polynomial
below as a as a product of two binomials
so this is the same thing as
n
minus one
times n
plus three and once again you can check
this you can take this n minus one and
distribute it n minus 1 times n
is this term right over here n times n
minus 1 and then n minus 1 times 3 is
this term right over here n minus 1
times 3 or 3 times n minus 1.